[Music]
[Music]
good morning everybody it's a seven
o'clock you are very welcome to join us
for the breakfast show here on sky news
this monday morning for many families
though it's been a weekend of long
queues delays and frustration at
britain's airports hundreds of chewy
passengers waited for hours at
manchester airport before being told by
text that their holidays had been
cancelled can you imagine easyjet has
also cancelled 200 flights from gatwick
and british airways has asked passengers
to check in their luggage a day early
it's not just case at the airport
airports as well the rac is warning of
traffic jams as well with nearly 20
million of us trying to get away as the
bank holiday coincides with the half
term break in a few minutes i'm going to
be asking the technology minister chris
philp about his plans for the jubilee
weekend it's monday the 30th of may
british airways has asked passengers
flying from gatwick and heath road
terminal 5 to check their luggage in a
day early to ease congestion
airport bosses here in manchester have
apologized to holidaymakers after
reports some were told by the police to
collect their bags and go home after
waiting for hours
also ahead the french sports minister is
to meet with uefa after liverpool fans
were tear gassed at the champions league
final in paris
in the u.s president biden mourns with
the survivors of the texas school
shooting
prime minister under pressure as growing
numbers of conservative mps submit
letters calling for a vote of confidence
in his leadership
[Music]
ukraine's eurovision winners raised more
than 700 000 pounds for the country's
army by auctioning their winning trophy
also coming up on the programme for you
this morning wherever you're watching us
around the world we'll be speaking with
the military charity chosen to light one
of almost 3 000 beacons across the uk in
the run-up to the queen's platinum
jubilee
[Music]
and i'm going to be joined by the one
and only dj [ __ ] tony to talk about his
new book which tracks his story from a
youth of petty crime
to internationally renowned dj
[Music]
good morning everybody millions of
britons plan to celebrate the jubilee
holiday with a getaway to the sun or a
trip to the seaside
but many passengers have endured delays
and cancellations that have disrupted
their plans some of the most chaotic
scenes were in manchester where airport
bosses have apologized to travellers and
british airways is asking passengers at
heathrow and gatwick to drop their bags
off a day early to ease the congestion
becky is standing by at manchester
airport for us now what on earth's
happening becky good morning
hi yeah okay it's been a really hectic
weekend here and at airports across the
country as you mentioned people trying
to get away for those half-term getaways
but we've seen reports of delays and
really long queues and two passengers uh
trying to fly with the airline tui have
been hit really hard by this reports uh
that they were trying to fly out there
was a flight to coz passengers were
texted from the airline after waiting
hours at the airport saying the flight
had been cancelled and then police
rather than airline staff came out to
tell them to collect their bags and go
home also reports of passengers arriving
into the airport being told to go home
and that their bags would be delivered
to them there because there simply
wasn't the capacity to turn them around
at the airport in time now tui has
apologized for the inconvenience and
that they they blamed the delays on a
combination of factors but we know that
this industry has been hit really hard
during the pandemic having to scale down
and then having to scale back up again
for this summer a lot of staff have gone
on to work in other industries and
airports and airlines are trying to
recruit but just getting security
clearance for those staff can take weeks
now easyjet is another airline that's
been impacted they were already off to a
bad start they had to cancel 200 flights
on thursday due to a software failure
and they've said they'll be cancelling
another 200 flights in the next 10 days
affecting passengers at gatwick but
other airports hit two heathrow bristol
and airlines and airports are saying to
passengers it might seem like a sensible
thing to get there really early but that
can actually be the worst thing
passengers could do
in increasing those delays
okay becky thank you
very pleased to say the minister for
technology and digital economy chris
philp is with us this morning hi thanks
for joining us on the program i want to
start with what on earth happened in
paris over the weekend i know that your
boss nadine doris wants uefa to look
into it
that's right i mean i was horrified to
see those um pictures of fans including
some children disabled fans being pepper
sprayed by french police and from the
pictures i saw there was no obvious
justification for that kind of behaviour
so nadine i think is quite right to call
for uefa to urgently investigate exactly
what happened there because we don't
want to see football fans
least of all children and disabled fans
being pepper spayed by police in the way
that we saw um so i really am concerned
by it the government are as well and we
need uefa to properly investigate
exactly what happened and get to the
bottom of it
we've heard from a french minister just
a few moments ago actually talking about
saying that they were sorry that
children and
adults some adults have got caught up in
it but other french officials are less
sympathetic this
from the french interior minister yeah
uh gerald
forgive my pronunciation he claimed that
stewards were assaulted by britons who
forced entry without tickets or uh with
counterfeit tickets tweeted about it as
well
he said thousands of british supporters
without tickets or with counterfeit
tickets forced entry and sometimes
assaulted the stewards what would you
say in response to that well i think
this is why we need a proper
investigation by uefa to get to the
bottom of it but the pictures i saw um
certainly did not depict uh british fans
liverpool fans uh doing anything of the
sword um the pictures i saw showed fans
uh with tickets waiting to get in uh
being sprayed and i was deeply concerned
by that i'm a football fan myself
uh crystal palace fan and so not really
then kidding oh
so look we need to get this investigated
properly yeah um what about the
suggestions that fans were pushing their
way into the ground and they didn't have
tickets that's not the sort of behavior
that the government would condone
no it's not of course it isn't um but as
i say we need to get this um properly
looked into so we understand exactly
what happened but as i say i saw uh
footage of fans behaving in a perfectly
calm way um getting pepper sprayed and
that just strikes me looking at those
pictures as not appropriate so we need
an investigation to just get to the
bottom of all of this i think uefa are
best placed to do that and i hope they
uh get on with it and do it urgently
talk to me about what's going on in the
papers at the weekend suggesting that
carrie johnson's organised a couple of
parties uh in the downing street
flat now um and that and that is
continuing to rumble on should it be
investigated
well i think we've had an unbelievably
comprehensive set of investigations
going on now for a period of nearly six
months we've had obviously the sugray
investigation
published last week and we've also
actually interviewed i mean goodness
knows dozens or possibly even hundreds
of people in the course of her
investigation looked at emails messages
um and everything else and we've had the
metropolitan police investigation
which again has gone over and gone on
over a number of months and they
conducted that with full police powers
so having had two separate
investigations including by the police
over many months it's not immediately
obvious to me that we need
any more investigations when this has
probably been the most rightly it's
rightly been the most thoroughly
investigated um set of incidents in in
recent times but the suggestion is that
there are um whatsapp messages that put
her in the flat on the day of the prime
minister's birthday with other people in
the apartment as well messages uh that
sue gray has not seen
for completeness should we not just look
at that yeah so i saw this story saying
that a number 10 aide had said they had
further messages um but i also um saw
the commentary that obviously sue gray
had approached and the metropolitan
police
had approached everybody i think
including this aid um over the last few
months inviting them to hand over
whatever evidence they didn't want to do
that they did they didn't want to submit
it they wanted to show it to her but not
submit it they were anxious about it
coming back to them yeah and the thing i
read in the paper and i'm simply going
on what i saw in the paper i've got no
sort of special knowledge of this
suggested that offer um
that was made available the opportunity
of showing the message rather than
giving a copy um but it wasn't followed
up i'm simply going on what i saw um in
the paper as i said i've got no um
inside knowledge of this and but my
instinctive reaction is that there have
been two incredibly thorough
investigations that have gone on um and
unless there's something really striking
that hasn't been known about previously
then then i think they have been looked
into really thoroughly and and the
report was incredibly thorough and
another one to come obviously from mps
so we'll wait for that um talk to me
about the ministerial code um it looks
as though the pm's uh rewritten the
forward to the ministerial code removing
all reference to honesty integrity
transparency and accountability why has
it done that well the nolan principles
you're referring to i think run through
all of public life the decision to
update this code i believe was taken and
the decision to update it in this way
was taken i think about a year ago in
april 2021 all of the uh the rules about
the importance of being honest with
parliament and all of those things are
still in there
the main change which i think is
something which the um the committee on
standards in public life called for
themselves was uh for the ability to
have a graded series of sanctions so
just like in any workplace if somebody
breaks the rules and they don't
necessarily just get fired straight away
there might be other sanctions that fall
short of getting fired and i think the
rewrite simply um confirms that
relatively common sense principle but
why would the prime minister take out
those references in his own forward that
he only wrote i think in 2019 taking out
bullying harassment honesty integrity
transparency and accountability
why would he do that now so i mean the
forward gets updated periodically but
those those things you talked about are
of course in the in the body of the
ministerial code they haven't been
completely deleted they are still in
there and obviously things like you know
honesty integrity um proper behavior in
the workplace and so on
all of those things are still in the
ministerial code so why take the
magister forward well because the
forward is a general introduction and i
guess he just wanted to talk about um
whatever he wanted to talk about in that
forward they're all still in the code
right the forward is just an
introduction setting the scene all of
those things you've mentioned which are
obviously completely unacceptable
are still in the ministerial code in
black and white so they're not important
enough to be in the forward though as
far as the problem before the general
introduction all of those things are in
the ministerial code and of course
they're important yeah but you
understand why people might be quite
alarmed about that at the moment given
that the prime minister is accused of
misleading parliament
yes i do understand but the ministerial
code still makes clear that a misleading
parliament quite rightly is considered a
breach of the ministerial code we've
been reading in the papers this morning
about some funky new plans as far as
brexit is concerned and uh bringing back
imperial measures pounds and ounces in
the like is that really what people care
about when they're going to be i think
800 pounds poorer despite what the
government's offering them
as part of this 15 billion pound package
well i think it's just allowing a bit of
a bit of our national heritage and
culture back onto the back onto the shop
shelf and you mentioned the cost of
living and of course last week the
government announced a enormous 15
billion pound package to help the cost
of living challenges that we face and in
fact for the the
poorest one-third of households that
support package announced last week will
amount to 1
200 pounds you know really substantial
contribution and that's on top of
everything else we've had this year the
cut in fuel duty by five p elite the
national living wage
increased by a thousand pounds per year
um two million universal credit
claimants getting an extra thousand
pounds because the taper leaf taper rate
has been adjusted so the government is
is throwing everything at this cost of
living uh problem as we rightly should
and yet and yet and yet the house of
commons library says average earner will
be 800 pounds poorer despite those
support payments
well i mean i think as the chancellor
said last uh last week um you know we
this is a global uh cost of living
challenge it's not happening not just in
the uk it's happening in america
in france germany across the western
world caused by a whole number of things
um the uh bounce back from covid supply
chain problems in china where they're
still having lockdowns
the russia ukraine crisis a whole number
of issues
are feeding this across the western
world and what we're doing in the uk
is everything possible to try and
ameliorate and soften the blow that
these cost of living challenges are
posing what we unveiled last week was
far more than the labour party had
proposed the package this year so far
amounts to 37 billion pounds 100 people
are still gonna be worse off than that
and for the poor households it's well
over a thousand pounds yeah um okay it's
time to celebrate isn't it um this
weekend and uh we're all going to
jubilee parties i think you're going to
won
a garden party in uh in kenley which is
in uh in my croydon constituency
apparently if you've not um
applied appealed for a license to the
council then it's too late um and you
can't have a party a street party johnny
mercer one of your colleagues um has
tweeted saying uh these uh street
parties should be allowed to go ahead we
should not let killjoys spoil the
jubilee what do you think look well i
would just uh look like a fully
um with the problems you just described
i think it's fantastic we're celebrating
the queen's jubilee and i would just say
to local councils you know around the
country including mining croydon if you
do get a late application and maybe the
deadline is technically passed i would
just say the councils just show a little
bit of flexibility show a little bit of
uh willingness to accommodate people and
if you're at all able to you know please
do grant these requests even if they are
made technically after the deadline
let's just show a bit of flexibility and
pragmatism in support of her majesty's
70th jubilee there we go lend on and up
thank you very much indeed for joining
us it's great to see thanks a lot don't
forget of course we will be covering the
jubilee extensively here on sky news i'm
going to the palace on thursday i'm
going to send paul's indeed saint paul's
on friday and then back to the pageant
uh in the mall on sunday it's going to
be a lot of fun do join us let's have a
look what the papers are doing this
morning the metro has an image of crying
liverpool fans as the culture secretary
calls for a probe into the policing of
champions league final in paris
the mirror hears from a father who
claims riot police tear gassed his
nine-year-old son
the ft says central banks are raising
interest rates in the most widespread
tightening of monetary policy for more
than 20 years
the eye reports that boris johnson is
set to remove dozens of eu laws this
year in a bid to appease members of his
party and turn around low support
numbers
telegraph has details about a new
post-brexit scheme allowing students
leaving universities such as harvard and
yale to get uk visas
the times reports ministers fear six
million households could face blackouts
this winter if russia goes further in
cutting off gas supplies to the eu
the express leads on calls for patients
who miss gp appointments to be fined
claiming it is costing the nhs more than
1.4 million pounds a day
the mail says 12 million people will
celebrate the queen's platinum jubilee
with street parties next weekend
and you heard there from the minister
appealing to councils not to be killjoys
and if they receive late applications
wave them on through well with the uh
jubilee just around the corner of course
celebrations now just days away
discussing what we can expect from the
bank holiday weekend with the royal
biographer angela levin
also get more reaction to the chaos that
mods saturday's champions league final
with a labour mp who was caught up in
the trouble in paris
and in the next hour of the programme
joined by the shadow leveling up
secretary and mp for wigan that's lisa
nandy
franz's minister for sport will hold a
meeting this morning to discuss the
events that led to the chaotic scenes in
paris ahead of saturday night's
champions league final in paris she says
she regrets that children were impacted
by the use of tear gas the technology
minister chris phil told this program
there should be a full investigation in
zman rashid reports
it may not have been their night but for
liverpool it has been one hell of a
season
on sunday the city was a sea of red as
tens of thousands lined the streets to
welcome their team home from paris
hours before kickoff this the scene
outside the stud de france
chaos and struggle as tempers flared
uefa said thousands tried to enter with
fake tickets and many turned up late but
caught in the middle were liverpool fans
holding official tickets stranded with
no way inside
for many caught up in the clashes the
result was almost secondary and as they
returned to liverpool a huge sigh of
relief
it's a bit of a
recipe for disaster really it's just
poor planning an organization i thought
we'd done everything we were supposed to
do
and we were at the right gate at the
right time we followed the procedure and
we were tear gassed i think the fans are
totally exonerated if you read all the
press reports
and i think the
[Music]
the friends authorities should be a bit
embarrassed by the way that they behaved
if it's normal then fine but
their fans never behaved anything other
than
support of a football club despite all
the heartbreak liverpool have earned
this victory parade those players and
these fans still have something to
celebrate
but there's no doubt what happened in
paris before and after the match
is a major distraction we're intent on
ensuring that there's an independent
investigation and obviously we as the
club will be absolutely a part of that
and cooperative
and we look forward to making sure that
that's done and done well
this is a side that were once on target
to make footballing history but four
trophies were whittled down to just two
that may not have dampened the
celebrations
but the pandemonium in paris certainly
did intermittent rasheed sky news
liverpool
well there was violence in the french
city of san etienne last night
angry fans entered the pitch after
sanati and lost their playoff match
relegating them for the first time in 18
years fireworks were launched as players
were evacuated from the pitch police say
two officers and 17 supporters
what do we think what the minister had
to say good morning morning kay well he
said there's no justification for the
scenes that we saw in paris um over the
weekend which is a bit further than his
boss nadine doris has gone but he said
that she has called for an investigation
for uefa to investigate
what happened as a matter of urgency
because clearly we saw young children
pregnant women old people caught up in
this tear-gassing allegations of people
being hit with batons and the firm
message from the government is that a
lot of this is clearly unacceptable some
interesting mixed messages from the
french government the interior minister
as he put it to chris philp has
suggested that it was the liverpool fans
um with fake tickets who were to blame
but others in the french government
making clear that something clearly went
wrong and needs to be looked into so i
think it wasn't an aggressive comment
that he made towards the french
government but he said that we clearly
need to get to the bottom of it um and
as far as jubilee parties are concerned
let them eat cake
yes so lots of jubilee parties going on
across the country over the next few
days but not enough according to the
culture minister there's been reports
that local councils say it is now too
late to have a jubilee park
but uh chris phillips says they should
let people go ahead although these
things do take a while to organize so
i'm not sure how many could be done at
this late stage but he says that
councils should reconsider people's
requests i think the problem is that
people have organised a party but forgot
that they need to get a license
do you do you need a license from the
council yeah then some roads don't let
you have them i believe yeah but if you
apply now the government is saying via
the minister this morning that the
council really should
perhaps wave it through what do you
think about what he was saying about the
ministerial code being changed so i
think we're looking at where we are
taking stock of where partygate has got
to with about 34 mps having expressed
public reservations about boris johnson
an unknown number of those potentially
having submitted letters calling for a
no-confidence vote and i think what
we'll not add we'll probably add to
their concerns is the fact that a new
edition of the ministerial code which is
the standards that ministers and of
course the prime minister need to live
up to has been rewritten by boris
johnson with the forward taking out
words like integrity honesty
transparency no bullying and harassment
and while chris felt was saying that oh
this doesn't really matter he seemed a
little bit awkward there in trying to
defend why this has happened and i think
for many mps this is just the timing of
this in the middle of partygate will not
um particularly fill them with
confidence we mps are in their
constituencies at the moment parliament
is in half term it's in recess and they
will be taking soundings as to how the
public feel about boris johnson and
whether he's now become an electoral
liability and i think while we're not in
the numbers of mps where it looks like a
serious threat yet whether we get there
or not will be depending on how things
go the next few weeks a couple of
by-elections to come and then of course
that report um from mps into partygate
for now tomorrow's take at nine o'clock
look forward to it thanks very much
indeed uh
right now though let's take you to
ukraine where president zielenski has
sucked the head of his security service
in kharkiv accusing him of selfishly
caring only about his own interests
rather than working to defend the city
he announced the decision after making a
visit to troops on the front line
alastair standing by for us in kiev hi
ali uh updaters
yeah morning president zielenski made
that trip to hakeem yesterday uh
surprisingly it's the first he's
traveled outside of kiev by by some way
since the conflict started uh just over
three months ago on the 24th of february
hakiev from cube's about a four or five
hour drive so i think he was sending a
message domestically of support for the
troops on the front line and there's
been some quite fierce fighting around
hakeem uh but also clearly sending a
message to the kremlin that uh he is
able to
with some degree of freedom travel
around large swathes of his country
because of course let us not forget uh
no doubt the russians would have wanted
to at the very least have removed
president zlensky from power perhaps
even assassinated him as a part of their
invasion but they failed to do that uh
and i think zelensky is showing a
ruthless side as well when he doesn't
uh feel that the parts of the the
machinery of military and security are
operating well enough uh he is happy to
get rid of them and sack them as he did
yesterday uh elsewhere in the east very
fierce fighting still around the lahance
region particularly the town of several
donetsk it's almost street by street at
the moment uh one assumes that the
russians will take it and it's only a
matter of time but the ukrainians are
putting up a sterner defense defense and
i think we probably expected them to
however if the russians do capture it
that will mean that they've pretty much
taken the eastern dombass region and it
will be it'll be a victory of sorts for
vladimir putin but nothing like what he
would have expected and we'll see what
they do next where they turn their
sights then uh to mikolive and perhaps
on towards odessa
okay thanks very much ali thank you
looking at some of today's other
headlines for you now
and graduates from the top 50
universities outside britain can apply
for a new visa scheme to come to the uk
from today the route is open to those
holding a degree equivalent to a uk
bachelor's or postgraduate degree
awarded no more than five years before
the application date the visa will allow
eligible individuals and their
dependents to move to the uk without a
prior job offer and will cost 715 pounds
a table will be set for the victims of
the grenfell fire during the queen's
platinum jubilee celebrations
72 place cards plates cups flags and
bunting will be laid out to remember the
people killed in the tower block fire
the sale of chelsea football club is
expected to be completed today after a
final and definitive agreement was
reached with the consortium fronted by
u.s businessman todd bowley the premier
league and uk government have approved
the 4.25 billion pound takeover
us president joe biden has said he is
committed to turning pain into action he
made the pledge after meeting with the
families of 19 students and two teachers
who were shot dead in the texas school
shooting from uvalde here's greg marlon
[Music]
on a day of mourning in uvalde the visit
that every city must dread the motorcade
of a president carrying a nation's
condolences for unimaginable loss
joe and jill biden went straight to the
memorial at the rob elementary school
the scene of such horror on tuesday
president and first lady herself a
teacher of course paying their respects
this has become a sad ritual for
american presidents so many victims of
gun violence in so many communities
but for the people of uvalde at the end
of such a traumatic week thoughts were
with their neighbors who lost so much
we go home to our kids and
unfortunately they can't and this is
something that
you rather always be remembered because
of this tragedy and it's one thing that
you know you don't want to be remembered
this way you always want to be
remembering something positive
[Music]
the questions about the speed of the
police response on tuesday have now
prompted the department of justice to
open what they call a critical incident
review to see if lessons can be learned
just one of the reckonings america is
facing
while this visit was about consoling and
supporting the community joe biden knows
there are big questions for politicians
including him about whether anything can
be done to change a culture that allows
these things to happen
this was the chant that confronted the
president here a plea for him to do
something
[Applause]
we will he replied but is that a promise
he can keep
greg milam sky news uvalde in texas
quick look at what's happening ahead of
the jubilee weekend the weather i'm
talking about of course
warm memories wherever you go
[Music]
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
cool unsettled conditions over the next
few days should clear up yay to leave
more benign weather for the jubilee
weekend it's a chilly start to the day
with a touch of frost in some rural
parts
the weather sponsored by qatar airways
not really sure what benign weather
looks like but i'm going to take it as a
plus now ukraine's eurovision winners
have raised more than 700 000 pounds for
the ukrainian army by auctioning their
trophy
[Music]
orchestra won the song contest earlier
this month with their entry stefania
they'd been on the streets fighting off
russian aggressors just weeks before
taking to the stage in turin the contest
trophy makers have promised to make them
a replacement for free
that's cool isn't it speaking of cool
have a look at these cool pics one of
britain's most iconic landmarks
featuring britain's most iconic person
images of queen elizabeth throughout her
years on the throne have been projected
onto stonehenge to mark her platinum
jubilee it starts with her coronation
and features pictures of her riding a
horse and walking her beloved corgis do
you know the name of the first ever
corgi that she had
susan susan just one of many tributes
that we'll see throughout this week as
the country comes together to mark her
majesty's 70 years
on the throne that probably is susan
right there
still to come after the break we'll get
more reaction to events that marred
saturday's champions league final with a
liverpool mp who was caught up in the
chaos
[Music]
hello again everybody welcome back to
the breakfast show here on sky news the
french sports minister says she regrets
that children were impacted by the use
of tear gas during the chaotic scenes
before saturday's champions league final
in paris
government minister chris philp told
this programme there should be a full
investigation
british airways has asked passengers
flying from gatwick and heathrow
terminal 5 to check their luggage in a
day early to ease congestion
and president joe biden has said he is
committed to turning pain into action as
he met the families of 19 students and
two teachers who were shot dead in the
texas school shooting
in the last half an hour the government
minister has told me he saw no
justification for scenes that saw
liverpool fans tear gassed by french
police ahead of saturday's champions
league final he also said european
footballers governing body uefa should
lead a full investigation
i was horrified to see those
pictures of fans including some children
disabled fans being pepper sprayed by
french police and from the pictures i
saw there was no obvious justification
for that kind of behavior so nadine i
think is quite right to call for uefa to
urgently investigate exactly what
happened there because we don't want to
see football fans
least of all children and disabled fans
being pepper spayed by police in the way
that we saw um so i really am concerned
by it the government are as well and we
need uefa to properly investigate
exactly what happened and get to the
bottom of it
well i also asked the minister about
reports that local councils may reject
applications to hold jubilee street
parties after deadlines have passed mr
philp urged local authorities to be
lenient on those looking to celebrate
over the bank holiday weekend
well i would just uh look i could fully
sympathize um with the problems you just
described i think it's fantastic we're
celebrating the queen's jubilee and i
would just say to local councils you
know around the country including
moaning croydon if you do get a late
application and maybe the deadline is
technically passed i would just say the
councils just show a little bit of
flexibility
show a little bit of uh willingness to
accommodate people and if you're at all
able to you know please do grant these
requests even if they are made
technically after the deadline let's
just show a bit of flexibility and
pragmatism in support of her majesty's
seventh year jubilee
angela's here to talk to us about the uh
celebrations heard there from the
minister saying that the council should
be more lenient with these licenses
everybody wants to celebrate millions
and millions of us yes i think the
numbers have gone up at the last minute
as they usually do yeah i think oh well
we'll see and all that but actually the
feeling that we've had such a miserable
time that we want to celebrate and this
is a lovely reason to celebrate meet
your neighbors you might they might have
moved in two years ago and you've never
seen them i think it's really mean for
the councils to say they're going to be
fine why why why why should they and
they said well you can't close the road
um well you can close the road just for
a few minutes and well for an hour or so
and have a nice time i think it's really
stingy yeah well the government agrees
so let's see what happens as a result of
that
the queen is not going to the races
apparently yes um i thought that would
be the one that she would really like to
go to that and some pools for the
ceremony
but on friday yes but i think maybe
thursday and friday itself is going to
be too much thursday is very busy
indeed and
i think she just wanted to take a break
but also
uh her three horses that were supposed
to be in the derby aren't there so i
think that she's a bit miffed about that
it's a shame because the jockeys were
all going to uh create a guard of honor
for her yes 40 jockeys that have been
working with her over many many decades
were going to dress up in the colors
that they should be
the queen's colors which is mauve red
and gold
and their stand there as she came up and
the car was going to bring her right
to the royal spot so she almost didn't
have to walk at all
so that that is a shame but rumor has it
that
as an alternative she's a birthday party
isn't there she'll meet lilybit who will
be one or is one already was going to
have a party or at least she's going to
meet her great-grandmother
she's just one so
i think it will be quite baffling who
this particular woman is for her but um
that that's a possible alternative but
harry and megan are keeping it unsure
when they're coming what they're coming
to
and how it's all going to work for them
so um well we see them on the balcony
we're talking about obviously the sussex
will we see them on the balcony uh no
the queen's been firm about that and the
way she's done it is to say if you're
not a working royal you can't be on it
and that's a way of actually stopping um
prince
prince andrew from going up because
there will think there will be
quite a a feeling of anger um amongst
the storm when he's doing that so it
rather than do the one is in and one is
out actually
neither of them can come but again i
think you know prince harry might
persuade her to let at the last minute
because instead of going to derby she's
sinking or we're being offered that she
couldn't she could come on the balcony
twice
you see so maybe one is actually when
it's the trooping the color that won't
come on there but another one maybe they
will um i just hope they don't take it
over and everybody's busy
writing and talking about them and not
about having no absolutely not hope
absolutely
her occasion it's absolutely unique
in our history never going to happen
again is it 70 years on the throne no
ever anyway no and i hope that we just
focus on her and
make sure that she has the most
wonderful time as well as us we follow
it but she's going to have them yeah
i've been prepping for the pageant on
the sunday uh with so many people taking
part in it along the mile i'm not sure
how much i can tell you about it but
it's going to be spectacular well it
sounds spectacular actually they've got
everybody they've got every type of
music you can imagine jazz classical pop
you name it they've got it they've got
so many celebrities coming singing and
dancing and it will be absolutely
superb um where are you going to be
i don't know yet i've been somewhere but
i don't know exactly where yet okay um i
know i'm going to be in um buckingham
palace on thursday but that's um that's
it but i find it very exciting and so
happy that it's a really positive
occasion which we really need um and we
can all sing and wave flags and be a bit
sort of jolly yeah i'm really looking
forward to it it's great to see you
angela thank you so much for joining us
on the program this morning so where are
you going to be for the jubilee
celebrations why not
celebrate with us
the queen is about to celebrate her
platinum jubilee
something that no other monarch has done
that's 70 years of duty dedication and
service
sky news will bring you the celebrations
and pageantry to mark this historic
occasion plus
a very special guest i'll be joining the
sky news team as we celebrate the very
best of britain and we cannot wait
that's the platinum jubilee on sky news
[Music]
all right let's get more now on the
chaotic scenes that marred saturday's
champions league final between liverpool
and real madrid
the technology minister chris phelp told
this programme that the use of pepper
spray against fans behaving calmly was
unjustifiable and uefa should
investigate what happened labour mp for
liverpool west derby that's ian byrne
was caught up in the chaos outside the
stad de france and he's with us now hi
thanks for joining us on the program
talk us through what it was like
hey good morning it was a river yeah
there's no other ways to describe it was
absolutely horrific and as someone that
was at ellsbury
in 1989
now we've bought so many terrible
memories flooding back i'm sure many
many people over there experience that
scene
flashback it was just awful pleasing
stupid
extremely hostile atmosphere from the
get-go you know and i think we've got to
remember this is the premiere
football occasion in europe and to these
football fans like animals which you did
is unforgivable
what caused it
all for policing awful stupidin
mismanagements around the grounds you
know gates shut
i mean i think we were there an hour
before we got an hour before then be
seen
well i was entertaining and chain style
in
section a
i think he was 13 10 styles and two were
actually open so you can imagine what
was happening with people trying to
funnel in
uh it was it was just awful people
getting crushed kids
uh
it was a very very awful experience okay
and and when i got through
after an hour
we got eventually got through the other
side and was literally begging the
security guards to open up the other day
the other remaining change styles it
should no avail it was actually with
liverpool football club students on the
other side and they were just powerless
they weren't getting taken any notice of
so it was absolutely chaotic
why do you think french authorities are
blaming liverpool fans
because that's what they do is the easy
thing to do isn't it but back in 1989
territory aren't we where the lies and
smears about hillsboro it went out
really quickly and that narrative was
set so
you know when i got into the grounds i
was absolutely appalled when we seen the
signs saying that due to a late arrival
of fans there was people there who'd
been there three and a half hours we
were killed in getting pepper sprayed
tear gassed no this is a football
occasion you know we've all seen the
footage we've seen the photos you know
and
i just thank god this saying that the
journalists were there you know sky
sports news have been fantastic the
british journalists have covered it
wonderfully well so the real truth about
what happened is i'm there now so
obviously they've had to go back but
uefa and the financial authorities need
to hang their legs in shame about what
happened tonight
what do you say um to the suggestions
that um fans arrived without tickets and
stormed into the ground
well i can speak for my personal
experience so my eyewitness account was
there was
lots and lots of locals who were hanging
around the ground obviously the stories
about morgan and people and people
getting tickets stolen well i seen lots
and lots of locals storming over the
walls storming over the gates where i
was standing in the game and we
eventually got in about 20 minutes into
the game
and there was lots of
local fans who didn't make colours they
would just you just come in to do
whatever he wanted to do within the
stadium so that's my personal experience
kate that's what i see and i'll say as
it is
i know that you've written to the
foreign secretary or are about to to ask
her for an investigation we were
speaking to the government minister this
morning the government already calling
for that investigation what do you want
it to cover
well i think we've got to make sure that
the scenes what we experienced on
saturday and never ever replicated again
at any sport and occasion you know and
the stud defense holds many different
sporting finals i think it's got the
world cup i think the olympics
and
we need to make sure that lessons
delaying from what happened you know
this was another football thing this was
a football thing manchester city could
have been in that position
quite easily chelsea any other football
club that was in the champions league
wouldn't have exactly the same
experiences so i think from our my
perspective of the football authorities
in this country the governments
need to come together and say enough is
enough we just will not accept that and
moving forward a new way for the
gosselin lessons about the absolute
debate for what we see in safety but
also everything around the final the
tickle allocation there's lots and lots
to learn so we need a full independence
investigation and to be honest i think
we need an apology from the french
authorities because
some of the tweets that came out from
politicians who were there uh
belize no there's no other way to
describe it you know what the knowledge
of the time to be set by french
politicians and they need to apologize
to the liverpool football club the
support of police as well
the uefa's weighed in as well though
haven't they claiming that the problems
outside the the venue were caused by
thousands of fans who'd purchased fake
tickets which did not work in the
turnstiles and they did say they were
sympathetic to those affected and with
further review uh these matters urgently
but again blaming the fans
yeah well as i said it's an easy thing
to do okay you know
for mistakes that were made by the
authorities and their
uh and uefa the easiest thing in the
world is to blame football fans blame
liverpool fans and we won't get to debut
what we need to get to which is the
truth about what happened and as i said
i never ever won any football fan or any
sport and fun to ever go through what we
experienced on saturday nights you know
and there'd be many sales people will be
i'm sure putting on they're putting out
their experiences and rankings to
football clubs thanks to local mps so i
think that all needs to be collated but
for me it's about ensuring that no one
has to go through that again you know i
never thought i'd see that again yeah
after the experience of hillsboro but
you know i think
before
the
patients uh the behavior of the
liverpool football fans they evaded the
catastrophe which was right at the door
of the french authorities in uefa let's
make no mistake about that
okay uh well i'm glad you're home safe
thanks very much indeed for joining us
thank you
looking at some of the other headlines
for you this morning nepal's army says
it's located the crush site of a plane
that went missing on sunday with 22
people on board the tara airplane was on
a scheduled flight from pakara to
johnson
at least 57 people have been killed and
thousands displaced as heavy rain led to
landslides in the northeast of brazil
it's the fourth major flood in the
country in five months
experts say monkey pox represents a
moderate risk to overall public health
at a global level the world health
organization has said that the sudden
appearance of the disease in countries
where it's not usually found suggests
undetected transmission for some time
more cases are expected as testing
expands
let's return to the war in ukraine now
and eu leaders are meeting this morning
to discuss the next phase of europe's
diplomatic response and in ukraine's
pulverized east president
vladimir zelinsky has said the entire
critical infrastructure of the besieged
city of sivera donetsk has been
destroyed by russian artillery
chair of the house of commons defense
select committee that's tobias elwood is
joining us now hello mr elwood thanks
for joining us on the programme this
morning um what's your latest assessment
of what's happening in ukraine
exactly as you say the fighting is now
around several next uh if this falls
then russian forces will continue
pressing uh west they'll consolidate in
that area my concern then is that they
will then move around to the port of
odessa
and they'll do to odessa what they did
to maripo which you've been reporting on
uh in the past if that happens ukraine
is then landlocked but more critically
that grain will not be able to get out
of the country and we're now coming to
realize that ukraine is the breadbasket
for europe and beyond we face a cost of
living crisis here that's in part fueled
by the war in ukraine we need to help
ukrainians more at the moment
we see the uh
attention span fading to some degree and
i make it very very clear now the way i
see it from my position is that russia
is actually winning in its objectives
the ukraine is outnumbered and outgunned
and we need to support our ukrainian
friends more than we're doing at the
moment
in what way
it's longer-range missile systems um
what's happening is that the brave
ukrainian forces are trying to hold
ground or even push forward and they
can't contend
with the russian missile systems uh
which are attacking them from 70
kilometers away so we need to upgrade
the type of equipment that we're private
providing to ukraine but also there's a
wider question of what actually we're
trying to achieve
what is the ultimate objective i believe
it should be to flush out ukraine
russian forces in their in its entirety
from ukraine mainland we need to clarify
that mission because that itself then
dictates the type of weapon systems we
need to support there also needs to be a
coalition of the willing nato formally
is still sitting on its hands this most
formidable alliance is just watching
what's going on there needs to be
coordination of what we're doing in
ukraine recognizing that if we don't put
out the fire there this fire will spread
to other parts of europe that's what
putin's intention is
before i'll let you go i want to ask you
about the um latest situation as far as
your prime minister is concerned what
next for him now where's where's he
going from here he looks as though um he
has um
more lives than a cat
it does seem that way but i say that the
party is increasingly in a
difficult pace place this is going to be
a testing summer
polling is now showing we could lose 90
seats
um and we know we're we still seem to be
in denial and it's time
it's time to shake off this this
partisan stockholm syndrome i believe
our party brand is suffering we will
lose the next election on current
trajectory as reflected in recent
elections by local elections and no
doubt in the tough by-elections ahead
and when you get
the the church elders in the party such
as lord hague now expressing who's
concerned you know we need to listen and
as i predicted we're now going to get a
steady drum beat of colleagues no
willing and no longer willing to defend
or indeed dismiss what happened in
number 10. the party does seem to be a
little adrift at the moment as to what
we stand for our big vision uh what our
answers are uh to uh to provide the
solutions the innovative solutions to
the challenges ahead
um what have you been told in private in
the tea rooms uh mr ellwood do you have
more public support in your view
of the prime minister than it seems to
be when we saw you being heckled uh by
your own colleagues the other day in the
chamber
well it was one individual colleague uh
who who heckled me but uh uh absolutely
what was really interesting after that
uh is the amount of support privately
that people are saying saying they will
go back and they will make judges they
will speak to their associations they
will see the outcome of the local uh
elections
but there's not only just a concern
on the conduct of behavior at number 10
because that's breached the trust with
the british people it's now
concerns about number 10 thinking what
our policies are what we are now seeing
is an approach to shore up
and chase a slice of uh the electorate
with policies such as bringing back
imperial measurements um
there will be some people in our party
which will like this nostalgic policy in
the hope that it's enough to win the
next
next election but this is not the case
this is not one nation conservative
thinking that's required to appeal
beyond our base
it's far from the inspirational
visionary progressive thinking that we
require and it fits into a pattern i'm
afraid of micro announcements that are
increasingly um thrown out there uh
which actually is is showing further
discontent with uh with more mps
now i know that he doesn't speak
particularly fondly of you at the moment
in downing street but somebody who
speaks very fondly of the prime minister
is the ukrainian president you know and
he's the hero of the world at the moment
some people would see him as that so
that sort of ringing endorsement
means that the prime minister has
support
um from all quarters
uh yes but don't assume that just
because boris johnson may or may not be
replaced that our foreign policy will
change in ukraine we've been providing
weapon systems and support since 2014
and as as i've just been illustrating
there is a vacuum of leadership in
europe at the moment that's where i'd
like to see britain step forward in
consolidating a coalition if nato isn't
going to do it that's what i'd like to
see uh britain do so let's not use
ukraine as a fig leaf
to deny the fact that we have a serious
issue in our party that needs to be
addressed there's now imminent talk of a
reshuffle to remove any further
questioning voices you know that might
criticize what the prime minister does
in private this is exactly the wrong way
we should be going it's the absence of
those inquisitive minds being heard that
actually allowed legislation to support
owen patterson for example to go
unscrutinized yeah i'm guessing you
wouldn't be waiting for the call if
there was a reshuffle
uh no i wouldn't i'm not sure that i
would answer that
we need some big changes to take place
in our party we've been in 12 years
there's no doubt about it that's tough
for any party in government but we need
to show the nation that we're willing to
refresh we're energized and what when
you know there's a desire a passion to
have the policies that will actually
earn the trust to win us the next
general election okay it's great to talk
to you as always thanks very much indeed
for joining us thank you
let's go to windsor should we ahead of
the platinum jubilee celebrations which
kick off in earnest later on this week
shingi is there
for us we believe that her majesty is
going to be
hopefully getting together with her
latest great grandchild there later on
in the week
that's right she'll get her own private
moment of celebration before the very
public jubilee celebrations we
understand that prince harry and his
wife meghan markle will be staying here
at windsor in frogmore cottage and
they'll get the chance to go to the
thanksgiving service at some pools on
the weekend but that also on the weekend
fittingly only libert's first birthday
she may get the chance to spend some
time with the queen obviously her name's
sick and that's that'll be quite quite a
big moment alongside jubilee
celebrations across the country with 16
000 street parties planned
well thanks very much we'll come back to
you in the next hour also talking about
what the government's saying about
council means
you